show you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol
of choice christie wright ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today open phones
at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five you guys jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money abby's
with us in lexington kentucky hi abby
welcome to the ramsey show
hey how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so my husband and i are awaiting the
arrival of our
first baby any day now
what is it um it's a boy absolutely
um and we have wonderful
and supportive families who are you know
wanting to
help invest for this baby and so um
they brought up the idea someone
mentioned to them that they
like are interested in purchasing a life
insurance policy for the baby once
they're born
and my husband and i don't particularly
feel like that's the best
idea but we don't know how to articulate
why
or even maybe what we would prefer
instead um we do work with investment
professionals for our you know our
investing that we do
um for retirement and so i guess
what would be the best option to suggest
you know should we set up a 529
should we set up a roth um how can they
can
what would be easiest for them to just
contribute to when they want to
what what would you suggest there's
nothing as stupid as a brand new
grandparent
i know i have lived it i
am that guy we want to do i mean this
you wouldn't believe the crap
i bought for babies on their first
christmas
stuff they can't use till they're 16. i
filled up the whole living room
my daughters were so disgusted with me
they're like you're keeping this at your
house i'm not taking this home
well it doesn't even make your kid can't
drive until he's 16 but you bought him
two
yeah oh yeah that they're sweet
they're sweet but they're just being
dumb you're right how do you
how do you always explain the life
insurance policy it's to replace income
right if someone was to pass whoever's
dependent on that person's income this
baby is no one dependent
on him well there and what's happened is
some stupid life insurance agent got a
hold of him and told him it was a way to
invest for college and let me tell you
where they're going to college if they
do it off a life insurance policy
they're not going to college
so um it's just a horrible investment
they're sweet but they're just doing it
wrong so we just need to
we just need to guide them a little bit
here and be and give them a lot of grace
because truthfully they're they're so
excited their brains aren't working
yeah so yeah i i think you're right i
think you go to your investment
professional and you set up a 529
and you go hey guys any of you that are
wanting to invest in their future
we would consider it an honor if you
would contribute to the 529 yeah for
college
and and hint hint the insurance is a
stupid idea
if they go buy it anyway you know
it's just one of those things the stupid
grandparent did that where they wasted
their money i mean
but it's a you know but you don't just
advice
from the other side of the aisle here
because i'm on the other side of this is
you're probably not going to keep them
from doing all the stupid things you
want them to not do
it's just this first i'm curious abby
did they ask you if you wanted that or
are they saying they're going to do that
no they had just mentioned that oh we
heard this was a good idea
we thought about doing it we're going to
talk to our insurance
it's not a hill yeah it's not a hill
worth dying on
i just say i would just do a drive-by on
it at some point and you have to do it
immediately but at some point go
hey you guys mentioned that life
insurance thing we don't do investing in
life insurance at our place we do it in
mutual funds and so we've got a 529 set
up and if you put it in there
we would that would be the way we would
prefer you do it and
but if they do it anyway don't get all
mad about it it's just them being stupid
yeah
that's what we figured it's no skin off
our teeth either way but just
if you know if there was a better way to
suggest
how would you how would you suggest it
from from her side when they mean
you've had to handle in-laws i i have
and i think if you just
it's not so much no to this idea as it
is hey we really like this idea so focus
on the yes focus on the the positive
keep it positive
but what i would find appealing what i
would think the grandparents would find
appealing about the 529 is
it's something so tangible you're
investing in their future their college
their education
and just say hey like we want to start
investing early and saving for their
college education for his college
education
if you want to do that that'd be really
cool that you could participate in
investing in his future in that way when
he's 18 he's going to get to go to
school because this money we start to
paint this picture and then i'll be able
to point back and go you know grandma
and grandpa were the ones who helped us
fund this that's right you're going to
college because of grandma and grandpa
and
you know they get the credit and stuff
or part of the credit or however all
that kind of thing so i just keep it
positive focus on what you do want them
to do not what you don't want them to do
and maybe they'll
they'll move in that direction yeah
because here's what's going to happen
after there's six or seven grandkids
running around
um they're going to get bored with all
this
the novelty wears off they're not well
they're not going to be as big a problem
because they're going to be there
their sugar is going to be dialed down a
little bit so
like i'm a lot more chill with number
seven than i was with number one right
i mean i had to have yeah i was the
problem papa dave with number one
how do we rate him in i told him the
team today dave during one of our shoots
my
my dad one of the ways that he shows
love he thinks the
larger the present physically larger the
more love i'm like dad i don't have any
more room in my house
large plastic things with motors in them
for boys yes i'm like no more
no more six of those cars if one is good
six is better
yes oh my gosh absolutely yeah
so funny yeah you do get uh it's that
way with kids i mean
the first one went off to college we
cried and the second one we cried for 10
minutes
the third one we appointed college
doesn't go that way and so
you know it's just like rachel talks
about that she's still scarred by it
yeah she's scarred by it she's got a lot
of scars
but uh so yeah it's uh choose your
battles because they're not going to
always be there
yep the battles aren't going to always
be there i mean yep um and
and so um it's a bigger deal to you
right
now than it will be with the third kid
it's a bigger deal
to them right now than it will be with
the seventh grandkid well because the
emotions do
you just kind of calm down a little bit
totally and i think how you approach
discussions
totally are different if the decision
doesn't directly affect you like if
you're talking about something like
they want to move next door to you
because they want to take care of the
kids every day like that affects you if
they get a life
insurance policy on the baby that
doesn't affect you in a real practical
day-to-day way
yeah and so that changes how you
approach it too yeah you can ignore the
stupidity because it's doing no damage
yeah
it's not really a fair bank account yeah
yeah that's exactly right but
i think a good thing is just a way to
redirect it but i always think of my
granny gave us
uh uh savings bonds which suck
i mean a horrible rate of return like
two percent or something that's just
what she wanted to do and she gave us a
50 or 100
savings bond for each kid every
christmas for chris for college
i would instantly cash them out and put
them in mutual funds because they suck
yeah you know but i always lied to her i
mean no i told her the truth sort of but
i mean she would say how's those savings
spawns doing i see they're great granny
they're getting their
great returns and my mutual fun because
after i cashed them out and put them in
a mutual fund they are great but so that
was partially true but yeah i got rid of
them as soon as i could but
but she was doing a the a nice thing the
wrong way or the
least efficient way and so you know we
just uh had to redirect because there
was no talking to her about it she was a
savings bond generation
that was the thing you know put all
their money in the cds and all the kids
money and savings bonds and this um
because we're children of the depression
all that stuff there you go this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices and
they make it
simple to shop blinds shades and
interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
thank you for joining us america this is
the ramsey show chrissy wright ramsay
personality
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
sarah's in pensacola high school women
let's hit the right button there
sarah's in pensacola hi sarah how are
you hi
thank you so much for having me sure
what's up
so i just finished my first semester of
grad school yesterday
and i was a resident assistant on campus
but my contract ends in about a week so
after that i'm moving back home to
continue school online i have another
job but i make
five or less hours a week and it only
pays 11 an hour
and i'd really like to set myself up in
my career to be financially stable so
i'm wondering should i hold off on baby
step four to make sure i can pay for
school
yes yes okay and then how can i make
sure that i
i actually set myself up financially to
go through this because i'm
not making enough money yeah you
obviously need to work more
yeah five hours a week yeah it says it's
supposed to be 10 to 15 but it's a
remote position and the work that i'm
actually
getting is not much but i don't really
know whether i should look for like an
internship or
another route what are you doing now
so i just received my bachelor's degree
in communications last semester
and my program now is in strategic
communication and leadership
i mean i mean for work what are you
doing for work that five hours
for work i currently work as a student
assistant for
um the center for cyber security at my
school okay
but i'm doing like community and public
relations kind of work so it is
in my field but it's not really exactly
what i'm trying to do i really want to
like
get a salary based kind of job and
make sure i can cash flow my college
basically
yeah i mean you need to get your income
up your hour's up and your pay up
and it doesn't matter if it's in the
field of what you want to do you just
need the money right now to pay for
school if you're doing it online
what would keep you from just going and
getting a job
that is in your field as if you just
graduated from college
because you did and take that income
and use that to pay for your online and
work a full-time job you don't need an
internship
so do i need to focus on finding a job
in my field first because
i want a bachelor's degree that'd be
wonderful okay
that'd be great but if you then just get
something
no i i think i would and i think i would
you know here
here's here's your a plus okay a job
that's 40 or
hours a week or more and you do your
online nights and weekends
and you finish up your masters or
whatever it is you're working on your
grad work there
that way oh and by the way this new job
uh not only is in your field but they
have a tuition reimbursement program and
they pay for it
wow i'm just getting a lot of home runs
here this is gonna be awesome
but uh yeah you're still trying to act
like a college student i think you just
go ahead and be the adult stuff
yeah i'm only 19 in you know grad school
so i'm kind of like
still trying to save money and figure
out so you blew through the four years
real fast huh i definitely did yeah
okay what am i doing now she's like i'm
acting 19 because i am 19 dave
give me one in the world what do you uh
what is it you're wanting to do when you
when when you're 30 what do you want to
be doing
if i'm being completely honest i started
thinking about this a little bit more
now that i started listening to your
show but i would love to be an author
one day
okay what do you want to do as a career
path
between now and then so i was looking
into that
and some jobs that i was looking to
applying for were actually content
marketing specialists yeah
um not exactly communications but oh no
it is communications all the journalism
students are filling up my content room
down here i got
tons of content folks on our team that
are writing in our voices and helping us
get
stuff out of here because we're putting
out so much product out of here every
day
and content specialists yes you're
totally qualified for that
oh and by the way you're under 40 which
means you can use a computer
yeah definitely yeah that's that's that
was age discrimination
as a joke she's like well of course i
can't dave what a weird statement i have
better keyboard skills
with my thumbs than you do dave but yeah
the uh uh
so yeah that's that's that's what yeah
yes go get a job as a content marketing
specialist
with a company that will pay for you to
finish your masters and that is a great
springboard into becoming an author 10
years from today
okay awesome i just wanted to make sure
i'm still on the right path with that
yeah because you're gonna you're gonna
write you're gonna write you know what
writers should do writers should write
yeah i started a blog and i'm like i
kind of want to continue that too on the
side
yeah absolutely that's a good place to
practice and do all kinds of stuff but
there's not much money in that
probably right now but yeah i mean you
get a job as a content marketing
specialist making 50k and they
have a tuition reimbursement benefit and
you're working 40 hours and you're doing
your online to finish up your grad work
and you're and you're pumping out
keyboard material all day long that is
actually relevant in the marketplace
you're starting to learn how to do stuff
that's awesome
and just flexing that muscle it's
amazing how on the other side of this on
the other side of your grad school
graduation
your writing muscles will be so much
stronger because you spent time writing
not just in the classroom not just for
homework but in real world scenarios and
on your blog
all of that's going to strengthen you as
a writer sarah let me tell you what's
underlying both of our answers on this
we're both looking at you going you
think your master's degree is your
secret sauce
we are talking to an incredible rock
star 19 year old
we think you are the secret sauce and i
think you've been putting the weight on
the wrong
sauce you is the answer kid
get it get it you know how to do it you
went ahead and got you so goal freaking
oriented she got a four-year degree at
19 years old
get it get it i mean that's it man it's
until you asked her age it was like you
were saying she's seeing herself as a
grad student and she seen herself
and i'm like no no you are a college
graduate at 19 by the way
that has a degree should go get a job
and oh by the way
is taking grad school classes that's the
afterthought
not the money and work piece of it and
man that's going to set you up so well
moms and dads teach your kids that
education is important but that
is not the secret sauce that the person
in the mirror is their secret sauce
no one cares about your degree or where
it came from they care can you do stuff
out here in the real world and you have
to be able to look at me
and articulately as the potential
employer
articulately describe that you can do
crap
and when you can do that i don't really
care
uh you know where you went to school i
don't care
what you're whatever you are i don't
care man woman black white pink purple i
don't care what you are
we have a lot of pink people that work
we do we've got a few look like they
fell in a tackle box but it's it's good
you know they're beautiful and they they
they they can do stuff man and that's
all i care about i know i mean that's
we love them it's all i care about
they're creative and they get stuff done
and so
that's what moms and dads you teach your
kids
look take their little face in your
hands you're the secret sauce
and yes you need to know stuff and get
you know get the degree
do the academic work but then don't lean
back and go well i've got a degree and
nobody gives a crap the other thing that
sarah's going to learn when she starts
writing is whether or not she wants to
keep writing
yeah because she may start writing and
realize i hate this i don't want to do
this i want to do a different path with
my skill set with my degree
dave do you know my degree is in
advertising i'm not using i'm not
working an advertising agency but i use
that education every day and what i do
teaching women through business boutique
with marketing
even on our team strategizing how we're
going to market and advertise stuff
but it doesn't have to be this perfect
linear path of using your degree exactly
like you think you're going to you're
going to learn a lot about yourself
sarah in these next few years
through doing some stuff of what you
want to do more of
and it's going to pull from your
education but maybe not exactly like you
think it will
yeah and by the way ladies and gentlemen
we can't keep christy from writing
it's impossible to stop her from writing
keep her away from the keyboard she's
doing it again dave when can i write my
next book he's like you haven't even
released this book and would you please
make it thinner
you got lots of words i do you got lots
of words i do it's wonderful
[Laughter]
and uh and i'm in the middle of a
writing project and it's
i'm quite the opposite i got lots of
words but they're not on paper i can put
them on paper now
rachel says every time she writes a book
she says i can't believe you like this
yeah i feel like i'm right i have a term
paper due but um
but yeah it's good i i enjoy what books
do but put them together so that
there's a beautiful thing happening here
y'all that um
there's something you take away from
that last call and that is is that
um we do not want to say
education is not important in america
just because there's an epic student
loan crisis
and fools have gotten degrees in
left-handed puppetry and feel entitled
that is not an education crisis that is
a
wisdom crisis and so
wisdom says knowledge is important
but it is not the thing it is
part of the thing the thing
is you you get up leave the cave kill
something drag at home
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
jason and keisha are with us hey guys
how are you
great dave great hey welcome welcome
where do you guys live
in memphis memphis tennessee just down
the road well welcome to nashville
and here to do a debt-free scream how
much have you paid off 165 thousand
dollars
how long did this take 26 months wow
and your range of income during that
time we started with 109
and finished at 2 18. okay got a few
increases and bumps a little sound
what in the world well tell us the story
what happened 26 months ago when what
happened to this income because it's a
double
november 2018
we were it was thanksgiving and uh
i always take off a couple of weeks for
thanksgiving and i was wandering around
the house i said we have
too much debt and
where's the money going so i came in and
i said hey i
know this guy that i was working for he
would always listen to you
i went in the garage and this is no joke
turned on the am dial
and there you were on 9 90 8. wow yes i
was
i told my wife i said we're going to do
this the wrong
thing to say what did you say
i had an attitude i mean i was starting
to make a lot more well he's in the
garage listening to am radio i mean
exactly that'll give you an attitude
right out of the garage with a
declaration right
there for it exactly so just the way and
we've been married um 21 years now and i
always would tell them it's your tone
it's not what you say is how you say it
and so i just didn't
want to be told that day i am amen
so i wrote down everything on the budget
wrote it out for made it clear where
we're going to start
this is how we're going to do i said
first just listen to him
she said i'm not listening to this old
guy
i did not uh it would have been accurate
it's okay
hey i said the same thing keisha it's
okay careful
so we started and we knew our
uh 20-year wedding renewal vow was
coming up and we wanted to pay for
cash because i told her we can't do it
unless we're out of debt
so we paid off that time eighty thousand
dollars
i told i said once it gets paid off we
can cash flow that you can upgrade your
ring
do all these things right here but we
have to pay this debt off
and believe it or not i won a trip on my
job
for a cruise oh we were in
charleston jacksonville jacksonville
she had an interview the first time for
the promotion that she got
uh-huh it seemed like everything started
falling in line
once we got the ball rolling yeah i mean
the more we start tithing giving to god
more time with him early in the morning
it seems like things just start
opening up for us and before we knew it
we were
out of debt for our 20 year wow well not
totally not still have one
big one which i have it written down to
the team but you asked too
just what what happened but i i had been
at
one job for like over 10 years and and i
i hated it i can say it now i hated it
so
we um i just wanted to go i mean i had
been working but i really think like
jason said everything fell in line when
we started to line up our
our finances and you know prioritize
so everything just fell in it gives you
a different level of confidence to face
something like a job change
it does and so once that started i mean
my interview was like on valentine's day
in
jacksonville and it it changed our life
wow
it did it turned out that day and then
after the wedding
renewal and all that done we had a
student loan hanging around
let me tell you how much to hey yeah she
grabbed that paper
it was well it started at about when we
first got married
about 23 000 i'm not a doctor i know you
ask
all the time who's the doctor lawyer
whatever i'm not neither
um it started at about twenty three
thousand by the time we paid it off
in march of this year it was eighty four
thousand
four hundred and fifty one dollars
and we paid that off in 11 months wow
ding ding so you just took all this new
wonderful income and dumped it
that's it just acted like it wasn't
there and threw it on that loan no
vacations
and done nothing we did only vacation we
got is i wanted if i win a trip
yeah on the job so he didn't win
anything this year
but but i mean it's i just can't
believe it i mean we even with the
student loan and we've used this as a
lesson just to
anyone our children will never have a
student loan i wouldn't advise
anybody so scholarships or cash yeah
that's
that that's it so it's been a life
change
20 years of marriage yeah 21 21 you ever
been dead free before now
never when i was like 18 yeah before
marriage
before marriage wow congratulations you
guys made me so proud of y'all thank you
you're rock stars man they're heroes
this is amazing
so the kiddos were watching all this
happen were they
uh uh going oh we got no life because
mom and dad have gone crazy and joined
the cult or were they
or were they learning they they were
learning we made them participate
okay and what i mean by participating i
don't know if they showed you the
pictures but we got the bubble on the
wall
yeah that we would color in every time
we send student loan their money
and yeah i mean oh there it is we got it
on youtube yeah it was just
and then we had another one that we paid
every month we just
lined everything up so you could see it
on a poster board yeah
that helps you need to you need to see
the traction the progress right and it
took a long time i will say once we got
probably midway it seemed like at first
it was going really fast and then
about the middle i'm like oh my goodness
you know
i knew we were gonna do it but it did um
it got a little tiresome and so we did
take a mini little break for a moment
just to get like new appliances i'm like
we got to do something i'm going to lose
yeah
we took a little break and we got right
back on it
okay but i'm i'm i'm a car guy today oh
i'm a car guy okay and that car got me
in trouble
uh-oh but it saved us because i paid it
off
okay and now that everything is paid off
you can enjoy it it's nothing like going
to the gas station just filling it up
and just
yep saying that drives different when
they're not dragging a payment book
oh man exactly we'll never do
never do it again what do you tell
people the secret to getting out of that
is
no secret i would say be intentional
that's one of my
favorite words so you have to be
intentional
you have to make just a definite
decision i'm going to do this
i'm going to do it that's it and write
it down and i'm a big
writer too so write the vision make it
plain so
write it stick to it and check your
progress
you know check in so how does it feel
now to
keep your money you get paid and you get
to keep that wonderful
although we're about to start now
tackling our mortgage that's all we have
okay so but it's still i mean it's
spring not knowing you have eighty four
thousand
plus yeah that's right hanging over from
well it's a hundred and sixty five
so yeah well it really is yeah yes yeah
so that the student
loan debt was um i guess the biggest
thorn in my side is
i tried to tell him when we first got
married well he knew i had that
but he didn't think it was important i
didn't just tell him i said it'll go
away like everybody said oh it's gonna
go
and i just disappeared i deferred
deferred deferred and
you know he you know hid from it and you
know and so i'm like
you just got to do this and i think you
said two before dave um
you made the debt the honest thing to do
would be to pay it so i can't
defer it or get someone to take care of
it or you know
not waiting on the government to do it
amen amen so the kiddos names and ages
let's get them in the shot with you come
on what are their names and ages
he's 17 and madison is 15 today
happy birthday all right great birthday
present very cool
all right jason and keisha we got a copy
of the legacy journey for you that's
your next steps
into uh completely changing your family
tree you are well on your way well done
and an extra copy of the total money
makeover for you to give to someone else
and
pay it forward with that so very very
well done jason and keisha
joshua and madison happy birthday
madison 165
000 paid off in 26 months making 109 to
218
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one we're dead
[Music]
i love it
that's how it's done right there boys
and girls i love it
160. amazing rock stars man those people
are heroes
well done this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well if you're tired of feeling stuck
with your money
like you'll never get out of debt or
you'll never save to the future it
sounds like you should go to the garage
and turn on your am radio
find some inspiration there but you
don't have to you can make progress with
your money and faster than you think the
only way to make it happen is with a
budget
and that's why you need a ramsey plus
membership you get access to the premium
version of our
every dollar budgeting app which is
world class
it'll help you plan out every dollar
that's why we called it that that you
spend and save before the month begins
you connect your budget to your bank
so it automatically enters your
transactions and you get custom
budget reports of course you've got
access to financial peace university the
nine-week class that has changed
millions of families lives and many many
many
other things coaches community tools
ramsey plus uh you get a budget you get
intentional with your money
people are doing their debt free screams
we always ask them how they did this
what the secret to getting out they
always say budget budget budget budget
if you want to do a free trial to ramsey
plus and check this out
it's a free trial all you do is text
trial 233
789 trial 233
789 our question today comes from
blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure or you pick the wrong
color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best possible
deal today's question comes from mckenna
in delaware
i'm currently working full time while
starting a small business selling fabric
and notions for quilters and textile
artists i feel like i'm behind even
though i only set my focus two months
ago how can i not be so impatient well
one of the things that i noticed in this
question dave is is this is the first
couple months
of adjusting to this side business and
getting started and so you're getting
used to a new schedule you're trying to
figure out okay what are the times that
i can work on this side business
and work on my goals so there's going to
be a grace period you were just talking
about the budget even when we start a
budget
you're learning how to do the budget
those first couple months you're
adjusting and figuring out it's the same
thing with your time when you've got a
new schedule
so i'd say there's a little bit of grace
in those early months for figuring out
when you're going to work when you work
best and making sure you actually have
those hours
set aside but you also just need in a
really practical way you need goals
you know what are your goals that are
realistic for the time that you're able
to allocate
and how are those goals reflected in
writing again similar to the budget
and on your calendar and hours and when
you can see it on paper it gives you a
more of a sense of control
and reduces some of that anxiety but i
will tell you dave this this
sentiment of i'm behind it is something
i hear
almost every day from women i feel like
i'm behind i feel like i'm behind and
there's a there's a little bit of
hey you're not behind this is not a race
in life
you are doing what's right for you in
your season you're not behind unless
you're literally behind
just this sentiment of feeling like
you're behind that's something that you
can set straight
um with yourself that you're not behind
you're just you're you're in control of
your business
and your time and your schedule and
you're not behind
when you set your goals they'll help you
do that
yeah they'll help you uh do away with
that sense of
being behind because you you either are
on track or you are behind
it's not a feeling right it's an
objective measurable
thing and so and and just to help you
with business especially when you're
starting a new business or
around here when we're launching a new
business within our business a new
product or a new idea
or something uh there's no way to know
if you're behind except you
guessed and you set a goal right now
you're the closer your near-term goals
should be very accurate and that means
that they should stretch you
but not be unrealistic um
you don't want to be sandbagging like oh
i can get that no i don't i don't i can
sleep in and get that goal no you got to
get up and get it done
right so it's not sandbagging but on the
other end it's not
pie in the sky on the near term the
further out
the goal is the more in the fog it is
the more it's okay for it to be a little
weird and a little large
yeah um i mean jim collins calls those
bee hags
big hairy audacious goals and when i
look out
way in the future on ramsey what are our
goals
those are like almost vision kind of
things they're fuzzy
versus uh budget numbers that somebody
by god better hit
right you know which is like in this
quarter right immediately
or by august or whatever you know and so
you know if we're launching a
uh a new book of christie writes which
we are
uh in the fall oh i'm not supposed to
tell that but i just did anyway anyway
but yeah i just i guess i just launched
it but that's great you know where you
can buy it yet so it's okay but i mean
you know we're sitting in the meeting
and i'm saying okay how many of those
are you thinking
what are our projections and i'm gonna
call our guys on that i mean
that's a goal that should be precise
right and then you can tell if you're
behind right
once we launch it we go okay we were
supposed to sell this many by this date
and you haven't or you have right we're
a head of goal or behind goal so we are
we're either ahead or behind
you're very sold them exactly on it so
you're one of the other then
but then but if i said okay you know
what is the
vision in 2030 for christy wright that's
a that's a
that's a more abstract painting rather
than precise
well and it goes back to what you teach
on goals dave where you talk about the
importance of
a goal being specific measurable and
having a time limit because so many
people think they have a goal
and it doesn't have those qualities it's
not a goal and they feel behind
because their goal is this i want to
lose weight and they always feel behind
because they never made it specific or
measurable to measure
be able to measure it against like
you're saying of knowing are we on track
or not
so making sure how much do you want to
lose in what period of time
right and uh it's very specific it's
very measurable
is it your goal or is it your mama's
goal you know all that kind of stuff and
so
you go okay i want to lose 30 pounds
well great how many times
yeah yeah yeah and so
you know or are you going to do that in
30 days or you're going to do that in
three years
and it changes the it changes the
situation right
and so you need a time limit on it so
you can do the math on it and lay it
down
on the near term goals and then it
transfers a feeling
of i'm behind okay then if you're behind
and it's a new project like hers then
you have to assess
okay was my goal unrealistic was it a
little pie in the sky because it was
brand new we were guessing right
it's a guess right you can call it a
forecast
you can call you can make up all these
words for it it's a guess
you don't know unless you've done
something very similar to parlay onto it
to do as an overlay to figure out the
math you
are guessing right never sold a book in
your life
how many books you gonna sell um yeah
there's no way of knowing
right you don't know right and so but i
mean the last two
books three books we've done around here
with ramsey personalities and
okay christie's fits in that genre and
it looks like rachel's in this regard it
looks like anthony's in that regard
we can use that as forecasting technique
and figure out we think we can sell that
many books right
uh and then we'll either hit that or
we'll do better or we'll do worse one or
two i mean you know
but but very very precise and you
give yourself a little attitude of going
okay it's brand new i've never just
started this business
if i didn't hit the goal do i have to
freak out and go oh well i didn't hit my
goal i guess i got to quit
no i mean the goals i set early in this
business i hit none of them
but they took me down the road towards
where i was supposed to go you got a lot
further than you would have had you not
had
them written down right and and i didn't
have that sense of being behind even
though i really
wasn't behind yeah aaron is with us in
colorado springs hi aaron welcome to the
ramsay show
uh thanks for having me on here sure
what's up
um i'm i probably have a good situation
um
but i'm kind of uh really afraid of
inflation
and i've gotten to where i'm at by just
kind of you said a set of budget
six years ago i had no money um my wife
and i worked our butts off we'd pay
everything off but our house
yeah and we have about a million dollars
sitting
um 250 is invested in certain things but
750 is
just in cash and i don't want to be left
behind but i
i think this whole market is kind of
propped up with a toothpick
and i think it's going to come down at
some point
so i'm really trying to figure out
what's my next step and i don't really
trust financial
advisors much of them um so just kind of
want to see
what your thought process is and and
where you're at on
maybe helping us with a good scenario
okay
well the thing you have to have is um
your your right to not
trust someone to take over your life and
run it for you
it's your job you have a million dollars
it's your job to manage a million
dollars way to go by the way
and so what you're what you do what i do
use financial advisors for is not to
tell me what to do but to teach me and
to give me information i didn't have
before
i need to know you need to know some
things about the market that you don't
know right now
because you you you think you know some
things that are causing you to make
these assumptions and markets propped up
with a toothpick
and it sounds like you've been reading
too much reading too much on the
internet to me
so you probably need to learn some
things about historical
rhythms to the stock market they're
fairly easy to understand
but you need someone that's in that
world that very calmly teaches you and
then you can
decide based on that knowledge how you
want to invest
but yeah you need somebody in your
corner that's not telling you what to do
not doing it for you but that's teaching
you
this is the ramsay show have a friend or
family member
that needs a daily dose of ramsay advice
in their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
kristy wright ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life
and your money thank you for being with
us open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
rachel's with us in
miami florida hi rachel how are you
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up
um i'm so happy to be on here i've been
listening to you guys for a while
so i have a car that's
worth about two thousand dollars but i
owe 2900 on it
and i'm not sure whether to repair it or
sell it
and then get a new one um caveats it is
under
my mom's name and um
other than that the car is running but
there's no ac
and i'm in miami it's pretty hot and all
the colts to 60 ac
et cetera are running about to a
thousand dollars
what what kind of car is it it's a mazda
cx7
it's like a mini suv what's your income
so right now my income is about 2 000 a
month
but i have about
12 000 in savings um
but i am interviewing for a management
consulting company so i'm interested
right now for a job that will give me
about 160 000 but again
i'm interviewing it's a big jump
that's a little change well yeah
i'm normally a freelancer so i decided
i'm a freelance consultant so i was like
you know what let me just go for
actually working for a consulting
company like mckenzie or boston
consulting group
okay wow all right i sure hope you pull
that off that'll be amazing
how old are you i'm 33.
excellent okay um
well go back to your original question
on the car itself the formula on a car
regardless of what's owed on it
if do i fix the car you ask yourself
what can i sell the car
for today and what could i sell it for
if i fixed it
if the difference is not equal to the
repair
you sell it now without fixing it so let
me give you an example
okay you said the car's worth two
thousand dollars if you spend a thousand
dollars on it does it make it worth
three
no it probably doesn't no not according
to carmax which i talked to them and
they were like
carmax is not selling carmax is buying
the car from you at wholesale
yeah they're buying it from you where
they can resell it and make a profit a
car like you've got should be sold to an
individual and you can make more on
it so you need to go to
kellybluebook.comkbb.com and look and
see what this car is worth on a private
sale so you put on craigslist and you
sell it to somebody
okay and let's use those numbers now you
do have a thousand dollars worth of
repairs to do to it i
do not think that the thousand dollars
worth of repairs is going to make the
car worth one thousand dollars more
on a two or three thousand dollar car i
don't think that's going to happen so
you're probably going to sell it as
is and you're going to have to write a
check in order to do that
if you sold it for 2 and you owe 2 900
you have to write a check for the 900
difference right
yes and then you got to write a check
and buy a car
yes which i'm definitely afraid of
because i
do only have 12 000 and i haven't landed
the new job and i just want to make sure
that
i don't put myself in a weird situation
yeah well i wouldn't
i i would spend uh no more than four or
five thousand dollars on a car in this
situation
and then if you start making 160 in a
year and take that five thousand dollar
car and buy you a fifteen thousand
dollar car
but you save up and pay cash for it
either way
okay so if you sell this car and you
write five thousand dollars out and you
go buy another little used car of some
kind
um so you should probably uh
if you're gonna do that uh two things i
think of is
one find a good local independent
mechanic that will pay
charge you a small fee for inspecting
the car and looking it over for you
okay and number two
um do you have um
uh if you're in a church do you have
some older guys in the church that might
help you
in this purchase or do you have an uncle
or a dad or something that might help
you in the purchase it is not that
you're not capable
but sometimes uh people around the car
business
might treat a 33 year old lady
differently than they would a crusty old
dude
well if it's your first time doing it it
is because this
would be the first car under my name
it's either been a company or my parents
yeah yeah would your dad go with you and
look at it with you and give you advice
and also kind of
uh back the boo dubs off on the car lot
to where you get
actually get a good deal
yeah i could go with my dad or my
boyfriend yeah either one
either one's fine and i'm not being
sexist but i'm telling you that people
in that business might be
i think you're perfectly capable of
doing it i just don't want you to get
mistreated
and i want you to get the best possible
deal and so i'm going to use every
technique
in the book well if you've never done it
before rachel like you're saying
then you wouldn't even know if you were
being taken advantage of bernard or not
if i
you know bought a car when i was 22 or
23 or something when it was my first
time
i didn't know the first time i had to
ask everybody to research bring people
with me
by this point i've bought and sold
several cars so i'm confident going into
that type of environment and i know what
to ask and i know when someone's trying
to
you know be shady but if it's your first
time you wouldn't know how to do that
and so yeah just having all the help in
your corners a great idea
yeah good stuff tom is with us in
scranton pennsylvania hey tom how are
you
good dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
okay we're brand new to you uh we're in
baby step two
may was our first every dollar budget
wow good for you
yeah hopefully it's like i don't know is
it a wild ride
brother yeah so my question is
i got something that doesn't plug in
real well um i've got
some loans on my tax deferred profit
sharing account
the account's worth about 400 000 in
company stock
well i it was i just moved it and
diversified it thanks to you
but um it should be 450
but i took these pro these loans out i'm
paying myself
five percent interest yeah they always
do um
and um i'm taking it it's taken out of
my paycheck
sure bi-weekly um do i treat that as
debt
yes put in line and take down yep put it
in your debt snowball
okay all right yeah wherever it goes the
thing is when
you get to it you will not be able to
pay extra on it every month
you'll have to just save up and pay it
off in one lump you'll have to because
they won't take extra payments
uh i think they do really um yeah
the program that i've seen but my other
option just to make sure
um because of covert i might be able to
put those payments on hold for six
months
no we want to get rid of the debt so you
treat it as debt and just put it
on right
yes yes trade it as debt it is because
it is dead and get rid of it
because i want you to have your 400 000
without anything leaning against it
um so yeah yeah definitely you'll make
more money
on your money than you're paying you on
your money
when you don't have this lien against it
so it's a much better
deal this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 dollars a month get
unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 dollars
a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
our famous 10 sale is here now you can
learn how to make
faster and real progress with your money
and other areas of your life when you
check out our famous 10
sale save up to 10 60 on 40
best-selling books including christy's
book the business boutique number one
best seller including the total money
makeover
which is a number one best seller been
on the best seller list for over a
thousand weeks now
wow that's amazing plus uh these make
great gifts shop our ten dollar sale at
the online store at ramseysolutions.com
that's not all we got a gift for you as
well you can enter to win our ramsey
cash giveaway we're giving away
500 cash every week and a grand prize
of five thousand dollars cash entered
daily for extra chances to win no
purchase is necessary of course you got
to be 18 or older
text cash 233 789
cash to 33789 solutions.com
store will get you in for those 10 sales
on those books you do not want to miss
out on the sale it is
i mean you buy a case of books for like
100 bucks i mean it's a deal
and and you can mix and match you get
rachel's and christie's and mine
and all the different books are in there
man ao's books everybody's there they're
all there
so jump in here we'll talk to you triple
eight eight two
five five two two five jessica is in san
francisco hi jessica welcome
to the ramsey show thanks dave for
taking my quotes an honor to speak with
you
you too um i'm on baby step
six and i'm about to inherit about 330
000 i have a loan balance
of about 338
coincidentally with an interest rate of
2.75
um my principal and interest every month
is about 1400
and so i'm considering using the
inheritance to either build
an accessory drawing unit or an invol
unit to
get rental income as opposed to paying
off the mortgage balance
and i just wanted your thoughts on that
well uh for 30 years we've taught people
the shortest distance between where you
are
and wealth is to
invest steadily in your 401ks and roth
iras
and stay out of debt and get out of debt
and the millionaire study that we did
with 10 000 millionaires
confirmed that theory that hypothesis
in that we found the typical millionaire
has a paid for home
and a million dollars plus in their
mutual funds and their retirement that's
the typical
thing i mean um they didn't make money
they didn't make money by doing an
in-law apartment they paid off their
house
so what would i do if i were in your
shoes i would pay off my house
the home is worth about 1.2 million
great
and when my you know when my dad passes
which hopefully he doesn't anytime soon
i will probably
inherit upwards of two million dollars
so i mean
wonderful a wonderful position here
um the you know being in the san
francisco bay area obviously if i could
build a shed
in the backyard and rent it out for more
than fourteen hundred dollars a month
so you can do whatever you wanna do
honey okay
if i woke up in your shoes i would pay
off your house then i would use my
increased cash flow and your income to
save up and do whatever additions you
want to do
and then when you inherit the other
money i'm going to buy real estate that
i pay cash for and or invested in mutual
funds
um i i think you're
uh i i don't want you making a dumb
decision based on what you may receive
in the future as an inheritance
that doesn't change the answer um and
staying in the debt staying in debt on
your home i mean you're going to be free
be 100 free you do not understand how
that's going to feel when you do that
and let me tell you if you if you pay
off this house and you hate being debt
free
you can go get your mortgage if you want
the other thing is we it's not that
we're saying not to do it it's just the
order in which you do things i think
people miss that when sometimes i feel
like when you say
do this first then do this they he all
here is no it's not no
it's just not right now it's right now
you're gonna pay off your debt and then
save up pay cash and do that
shed mother-in-law deal you want to do
and for extra income if you want to
it's just the order in which you do it
yeah and
oh by the way you've got a hundred
thousand dollars left over
i mean what kind of [ __ ] are you
building here so um
you know how much you spend on this
mother-in-law apartment
uh and be careful that you don't spend
money on an
improvement on a property that is not um
going to increase the value by what you
spend and some mother-in-law projects
don't increase the value by what you
spend matter of fact sometimes they just
mess up the house
and make it where it's not marketable
because a lot of people don't want a
house with a big mother-in-law
thing attached to the side of it some do
but the typical family doesn't want that
and so you could actually
harm the marketability of the house if
you're not careful in this process
so be very thoughtful get some real
estate people look at the idea with you
and make sure you're not
turning your property into a white
elephant we call it meaning something
very hard to get rid of well
even just think about the implications
of what you're suggesting to do because
aside from the financial which we're
talking about
you're talking about essentially
building this mother-in-law apartment
to be able to rent it to create the
income to pay for the debt when you
could just pay the debt right now and
avoid the headache of having a renter
and so it's like this is a much quicker
path to where you want to be which is
debt-free and not having the headache
and then like you said in the future if
you just want to do it for fun
to have that extra income fine but right
now it's almost like you're suggesting
it as a means to pay off this debt and
you don't need to
jonah is with us in pittsburgh hi jonah
what's up
hi dave it's jonah uh sorry i'm nervous
um so
i'm calling because my husband and i
have about over two hundred seventy
thousand dollars worth of debt
and student loans as much stuff and we
paid about a hundred thousand of them
um good lord for what
i'm a nurse practitioner and my husband
had a couple of things that he wanted to
do but
i'm having trouble hearing you your
voice is all over the place can you
speak directly into your phone please
yes i said i'm a nurse practitioner and
my husband's a social worker
and you have 270 000 in student loan
debt
uh i mean a bunch of others like there
was about 30 40 000 worth of like credit
card and consumer deductions remember it
was all three months
okay so my question was um
about 20 000 or so or is about a parent
plus loans in my mom
under my mom's name and i wanted to know
in terms of like baby steps too is that
like an honor like snowball or is it
something we should do later because i
mean we plan on paying it but i don't
know if we should just
you know go through the steps first and
then come back to it at some point or
just slowly pay it
so you have taken you have taken
emotional and moral ownership of this
debt even though it's legally not yours
correct yes my family's never been great
with debt
and money so yeah you're great with debt
that's for sure you got a bunch of it
yeah i hate it i'm trying to get rid of
it we've been doing this since 2019 now
okay so cool you're you're just gonna
put this in your debt snowball because
you're going to pay off the parent plus
loan
okay that's good to know you're treating
it like it's your debt right
yes well the problem is is that my
sisters took out paraplegics too so they
all kind of like meshed together
so i'm not really sure like which one's
mine
you need to get a real sure accounting
so you know when you're done
yeah definitely even if it's not a
certain loan you just come to agreement
with your parents that
i'm paying four hundred twenty two
dollars and after that i'm done or
whatever the number is
okay that's good i've always just
wondered this question
because this is this is a never-ending
thread you're gonna pull on this sweater
otherwise
yes and i want it done forever hey amen
yeah 270 000
[Music]
can't breathe it's just so normal now
it is and and just the amount of time
and income you have to
dedicate to paying backwards that's just
such an
uphill climb yeah we climb we just
finished up the rams research team just
finished a
survey a study done and they found that
44
of the people with debt are losing sleep
at night
oh i believe that because of that i
believe it i'm like
that means the other 65 are sleeping
good they're they are
55 percent they are feeling good about
their decisions i'm just trying to
understand neither are good 78 are
worried about it what's the other 22
doing you know i don't understand
i always wonder about these statistics
that we come up with around here
uh of course they're losing sleep i
remember being that scared
i couldn't breathe wow
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america we're
glad you're here christy wright ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author
is my co-host today you can join her on
the christy right podcast you can join
her
on her instagram which you should do
because she's pretty busy on instagram
she's uh like an addicting poster you
and anthony
ayo and christy have the most posts
going of anybody around here for sure
that's what our social team tells us
works they say frequency is good so
we're trying well you know yours is
actually good anthony's i'm kind of sick
of but um
i can give him a hard time about that
i'm kidding not much but yeah anyway
yeah it's just
it's everything in the world but yeah
and one of the things you've done is
you've taken your devotional and have
led people through it the 40 days
to get back to you that's right um and
uh
a best-selling devotional book a 40-day
devotional and you've gone through it
several different times on instagram
right yeah we're in the middle of it
right now in the 40 days following
easter
when in the bible jesus appeared to
people in the earth in the 40 days
following the resurrection so just
once a week i go live and read the day
um you know the excerpt from that day in
the scripture and
it's been fun so at christy b wright if
you want to follow along
absolutely jump in there carol is with
us in joplin
missouri hey carol how are you i'm good
how are you dave
better than i deserve what's up well i
was calling to get some of your advice
my husband and i purchased some property
last summer
with the intent of building on it and as
you know
i'm pretty sure this is how it is
everywhere but the
costs have went up and we recently found
out that we have the opportunity to make
some money on that we purchased the
property for 50 000 and we could make at
least 25 000 if not more so my question
is
um would you recommend that
we sell the property and make money on
it or
wait for prices to go down or just to go
ahead and build do you have any opinion
on that
[Music]
why are you leaving the property you're
in
well we currently rent so when we found
the property it was a
it was a rare find it's a couple acres
in town for where we live it's not
something that we usually come across
so we purchased it because it was a good
opportunity
what's your household income 95 000 a
year
what price range home are you thinking
of building on this property
um the property in the house would
probably end up costing altogether about
240
240 max okay all right with everything
we have in it
yes building uh materials have gone
through the roof and yes
in a lot of areas there's a shortage of
subs and labor and builders to do the
work
because there's a building boom uh and
there's a
a shortage of everything because the
factories weren't making it during covid
and now there is the shortage is causing
the prices to go up for instance lumber
has
gone up dramatically uh regardless of
what area of the country you're in
and labor in a lot of areas has gone up
because there's a shortage of labor
because the house
the the real estate's just quite hot in
a lot of areas so
all of that is true um and and so
what you've got to do is you have to
figure out if you build now
can you put together a manageable
situation a manageable situation is can
you somehow lock in some prices
with a builder that you trust and that
has the financial wherewithal
to ride this out and go ahead and build
it a
a builder that is financially
set and has enough profit margin built
in to absorb some of these increases
uh couldn't can pull off building for
you right now and then
you may be able to find one of those and
that's fine um
uh it sounds like your first house
um it's actually not we sold our house
about four years ago to
pay off debt so boeing did that we have
right now would be on the property that
we just recently purchased
so we've been running for about four
years okay um
saving up and going through the baby
steps so that's kind of where we're at
right now
yeah so so that's one thing you could do
is to find a builder then that had the
margin to
you know give you a locked in price and
that's going to mean you're paying a
pretty good profit to that builder
obviously and that's nothing wrong with
that that's just you know what you're
getting into
second thing is you can wait and just
sit there and run a while
and let this thing calm down a little
bit and then build
and basically what you would have spent
in increased
lumber packages you might spend on rent
so i'm not sure you're gaining a lot by
doing that
and then the third thing is what you're
talking about do you guys
you know is this particular piece of
property it sounds like it's a little
bit unique
it's not just a track lot of some kind
uh it's a unique property that might be
hard to replace later if you sold it
i mean if you sold it what i would do is
go buy an existing home
okay if you're gonna sell it i would say
you know is there is there a house
somewhere that we could look at that we
can find
without getting destroyed on price that
we would like as much or more than we
love the idea of building
in on this because it's just a very
difficult time to build right now
very difficult right so are is this lot
worth the hassle is this particular
uniqueness of this worth the hassle to
you
um because you could you know these the
least stressful path is sell it and buy
a house
okay that doesn't have a lot of stress
to it you see what i'm saying
yes i agree and even the waiting it
feels like to me the waiting if you are
going to wait it out because you want to
hold on to this property and see if the
you know the lumber prices go down and
all that even that feels so unknown
you know it's like when like when when
will that happen then you just feel like
you're i mean i don't know
i don't mind doing that if you owned but
while you're sitting there renting
i'd be tempted to and you're ready to
get back in the market you know you got
out of the market ready to get back in
the market i'm
tempted to just go buy a house yeah and
just be done with it i have a friend uh
that they're building right now
and they um you know locked in the
contract all the stuff this was you know
i don't know a month or two ago several
months ago
and the contractor just came back and
said we've never had to do this in 20
years in business but we have to use the
clause the addendum
that says we can increase the price
based on the materials going up we're so
sorry
and she's like how much and she doesn't
know and uh it is it's such a stressful
time
people think like well the real estate
market's crazy so i'll build
building is not a left no no no no no no
no no no it's not it's not it's not the
it's um building's hard anyway
anyway yeah um it'll strain your
marriage
anyway uh but on top of that um you know
it's just
because oh god man yeah but the uh but
but
it add to that then ever increasing
prices and
and you know on a home it's even worse
because it's more emotional
yeah like we're building the conference
center up here on the hill we're
breaking ground on it next month
and um here on our you know in the
ramsey
complex or whatever you want to call it
here whatever this is campus
and um uh you know they just gave me the
steel prices doubled
and it's got like millions of dollars i
mean that's a lot of money
but i wasn't nearly as emotional about
that as i would have been if it was my
house and it was
you know right because it's like ah my
house you know
right and sharon will be going ah you
know and all this stuff so yeah it's
you know it's just like oh crap that
sucks but you know so quickly by the
steel so we don't
get go up again on us but but yeah it's
the same thing
but it's it's more detached because it's
a commercial deal you're not living in
it
yeah yeah and um still a lot of money
but it's still it still piss you off but
it's not as bad it's something more
emotional when it's your home
because part of building a house is just
like a dream right you're doing it
you're you it's you
build something you don't like it's very
unique to you i'm customizing it i'm
picking the colors i'm doing whatever
and all the
maybe the floor plan and everything you
know and so part of that
is that the emotion of that is just
building a dream and
the danger is people think they're you
know
building their forever home their dream
home or something and if it takes 12
months to build it by the time you
finish you have new dreams anyway so
right
right you can't you can never keep up
but uh
uh but yeah it's it's it's a hard time
emotionally to go through that right now
and there's a lot of those clauses like
you're talking about are being activated
for the first time in 20 years
and nobody ever thought about them being
in a contract before we just looked over
and
whatever you know they're not gonna
they're not gonna do that
right and they never have right but yeah
but when something goes up
stinking 25 30 percent they have to look
at it and they do look at it
and it's a because for instance lumber
is the largest item
on your budget by far by far the highest
you know
of all the things in the components of
the home
and then when it says 25 on that that's
like a stinking
10 15 on the whole house right it's a
big deal right
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
christie wright ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
luisa is in charleston south carolina hi
luisa how are you
hey y'all thank you so much for taking
my call our pleasure how can we help
uh all right so here is my situation
i am sitting on in my savings about a
hundred and ten thousand
dollars that does not include my
emergency fund
and at the end of the school year i am
resigning
and i'm starting a new career totally
so i'm wondering what to do
with that 110 000 where should i invest
it so
if i need that cash quickly to replace
my salary i can get it but also
i don't want to just sitting there um
not appreciating
what which direction which type of
investment
could do that for me
well um what are you going to be doing
i'm going into real estate full-time
mm-hmm
you already like i'm already licensed
i'm already licensed i've dabbled but
um the market is hot and you
have to have time to commit to that and
i don't with my current
position in dabbling have you sold any
houses
no i've listed a few and then
no that's the quick answer did the
listings not sell
no the people did not want to
sell they ended up changing their mind
and they wanted to buy an investment
property
and so we're we're looking
okay so you had one listing
yes okay all right
hey so you're starting really from
scratch in the real estate business
having never really done a transaction
never not once real estate is in my
family so i've been around it
but brand new you married
i am your husband what's your husband
mike
he makes conservatively
52 000 can you guys live on that
while you're getting started we
uh we
no no we would need about 8 000 more
to be in the clear to break even eight
thousand you don't make eight thousand
now
no no no no no that would be just on his
salary
just a little bit but what we i'm sorry
8 000
more than his income
no on top of his income we would need
eight thousand more in a year to live on
so you could live on would you say
a year yeah oh geez yeah okay i was like
we're missing something here okay i
thought a month sorry a year
i thought a month okay no no no no we
don't need to worry about a year because
surely to god you're gonna sell a house
in a year
i'm worried about a month okay do you
all combine your finances luisa we do
okay i'll check in there okay so we've
got you paid
yeah okay so you're a few hundred
dollars
short a month of being able to cover it
with his
is all yes okay 700 bucks whatever
something like that
all right um well there's a couple
things you can do one is you can just
leave it all set there it's not going to
earn anything
and it's it is truly your backstop uh
but we need to budget out and say
okay we're gonna go six months with no
income
and what are your real estate expenses
so you need
six thousand dollars to cover that and
your real estate expenses so
i mean if we set aside twenty thousand
dollars and we leave it sitting there to
make sure that
you can supplement your household income
your husband's income
in order to cover until you get some
coming in and cover some of your
expenses because you're gonna have some
expenses
in the real estate business agreed
yes i've already paid for most of those
yeah but you're gonna have ongoing
expenses
every month that you haven't calculated
in your household budget here
so i'm gonna set 20 of the 100 aside and
i'm going to put the other 80
in a no load mutual fund no commission
mutual fund i use for stuff like this
an s p 500 fund an index fund because
there's no commission coming out so you
put it in there
the only downside is if the market goes
down before you pull it back out
right and it could
and so if you take that 80 000 and put
it in there and you lose
uh eight thousand dollars
is that going to kill you no no probably
piss you off but it will kill you
there anything we should watch out for
well i mean if you buy an s p 500 fund
it's going to do exactly what the stock
market does
and the number of times the stock market
goes down 10 in a year
and does it consistently year after year
after year is almost zero
so it does go down does go up does go
down does go up but the time
you know and ten percent of eighty
thousand is eight thousand dollars so
really you're putting
you know eight or ten thousand dollars
at risk for the hope of making
more than eight or ten thousand dollars
a year on this money instead of letting
you sit there one percent
right that's your trade-off and you've
got your other money sitting over here
to do your transition
with right
so this gives you an opportunity to do
both this gives you another
opportunity to make some money on the
majority of that savings you're talking
about and still have some backup for
this in between while you're working on
getting your real estate business going
it's a little bit it's the best of both
worlds yeah and then just keep the
pressure on yourself to get some dadgum
transactions going
and once you get the rhythm of the
transactions going then
you have a steady more predictable
income based on your performance not
based on the fact that it's a guarantee
because it's never a guarantee
but if you say all right i think i'm
going to make 50 to 100 000
a year i'm pretty comfortable doing this
i'm the transaction transaction
transaction
then you take this money and you apply
wherever you are on the baby steps
you cash it out of that mutual fund and
any money you didn't use your little
cushion fund it's over and above your
emergency fund
take all that cash and we throw it
wherever you're on the baby steps which
would probably be baby step six
in paying off your house early unless
your home is paid for we didn't get that
far but that's
that's what i would look at andrew's in
rock hill south carolina hey andrew
what's up
hey dave two calls from south carolina
back to back there we go
i've got a hsa account through my
employer and
every year they contribute three hundred
dollars after we complete some steps
as employees i'd like to take the money
from my hsa though about forty five
hundred dollars
and put it into a health savings
brokerage account
what is the best way to do that without
triggering
all kinds of extra suspicion from the
irs
uh we endorse a company and i use them
personally called health equity
that does just exactly that and they
they handle all of our hsas here at
ramsey i've got my personal hsa
in there look those guys up and um
there's no triggering it's not a problem
at all it's a very standard transaction
it's not an
audit flag or anything like that and
mine are invested in good mutual funds i
started an hsa when george bush first
put them in place a thousand years ago
and i've done them every single year and
i've never taken a dime out
and so it's in there growing completely
tax deferred tax-free
and guess what uh it basically is an
additional retirement account for me
because i don't use it
so moving money from one because my
employer only contributes to
their preferred bank but moving money
from that bank to
for example health equity solutions is
not going to is not going to
finish any issues there no we've never
seen it do that no
i don't have any reason to believe what
it would be like just rolling over an
ira or something that doesn't trigger an
audit
it doesn't it's not it's not a
suspicious thing because it's just very
often done where people have large
amounts of money i mean my hsa has got
several hundred thousand dollars in it
now
and um you know because i've just put i
fully funded
every year to keep the government's
hands off the taxes and then i'd never
use it i just whatever medical we've had
out of pocket we just paid it and um i'd
rather have that money sitting there
growing with no taxes
or tax deferred on it and so that's
again and i picked just good mutual
funds in that just like i did in a 401k
or a roth ira
are you using the hsa here and we do the
same we did the same way we just pay
medical out of pocket and just let it
grow yeah and you've got health equity
of course as well so you can pick mutual
funds with it
same thing same exact thing very good
yeah
so the hsa the savings portion of the
health
savings account is what we're discussing
here the
insurance portion is basically a high
deductible
health insurance plan that gives you
much cheaper premium and you can
not fund the savings account if you if
you're not in a position to
but once you're in a position to you can
fund it and use it
or you can do like we're talking about
and take it as yet an additional
tax sheltered investment account
very good stuff that puts this hour of
the ramsey show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it our
thanks to james charles our producer
kelly daniel our associate producer and
phone screener i'm dave ramsey your host
and we'll be back
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service
and didn't have a chance to write it
down don't worry we list everything
you've heard about during this episode
in the podcast show notes section or
head to thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host christy wright
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five allison is with us in
des moines iowa hi allison how are you
hey dave i'm good um honestly i'm
nervous and also overwhelmed my husband
and i we just started financial peace
university about two weeks ago
so we just
got done with step one uh we're working
on step two
i've done two plasectomies today good
and our class is moving on to step three
but we still have some things to work on
into
as well we have about thirty thousand in
debt
uh non-mortgage debt we have three kids
and our annual
income is just over eighty eight
thousand
um me being overwhelmed
um what's a reasonable time frame
for the snowball
well i just use big numbers there's a
lot of ways to look at it
um you're in ramsey plus you can jump in
there there's a snowball calculator in
there that'll help you run it out
and so you know that that's a uh the
nerdy detailed way to do it
but the way i look at it is 88 minus 30
is 58 you ought to be able to live on
58.
okay which means one year okay
but that's how i do it i mean it was
just a big number that's that means 2500
bucks a month
what you're just getting started so
that's probably like oh my god no
you know so i mean you haven't gotten
that far in yet you might and i'm saying
you'd have to average that you might
start out with less because you're just
getting started you just cut up the
credit cards today
and so you're not you're not in freak
mode yet when you get into freak beast
mode
and you start cutting this down cutting
your lifestyle to nothing because you're
completely obsessed with getting out of
debt you can do 30 000 on 88 in a year
that leaves you 50 it leaves you 58. but
you're going to have
you're going to have adjusted a whole
bunch of stuff i mean you're not going
out to eat you're not going on vacation
uh we've cleaned out all savings that's
not retirement and thrown it at the debt
we've chopped up every credit card we're
on a detailed budget
um we've sold so much stuff the kids
think they're next i mean we're
we're just you're gonna be in beast mode
you're following me
yeah absolutely selling things is
actually on my list to do i've started
posting some things already to help with
that uh step three
yeah so what's the 30 000 what kind of
debt
well a lot of its credit cards
and then it's also truck payment
um i'm looking how much
little over 13. okay so that's half of
it
yeah and then um we just moved into a
new house
um so that's new to us it's about a
thousand
of course that's not included but
we're we still own the last place and
you know we have been talking and we're
just not sure whether we're going to
dump money in to rent it out no sell it
sell it i was waiting i was like as soon
as as soon as you're done with this he's
going to tell you to sell that house
and see that's the thing too because we
want the seller to take it off the lot
too
because we're keeping the actual
property as it was just handed over
um by his grandpa who passed away
and you know the rest is credit cards
yeah yeah this is a trailer
yep it's a single-wide manufactured home
yeah it's a trailer yeah and so what do
you what do you gotta what do you owe on
it
uh nothing we actually um awesome
oh yeah what will it sell for that we
don't know because
i mean the inside does need some work
but
we're hoping to give me a guess 10 grand
i would say maybe 10. yeah that's what
i'm thinking
yeah great now we only got to pay off 20
grand
right and guess what that trailer is
going to be worth in five years
probably nothing
yeah why are we keeping something that's
going down in value take your 10 grand
get out of debt
sell it now
don't fix it it's not a fixer-upper it's
a trailer
sell it i will i will make sure to do
that because
my husband's listened to you for a while
we just never
acted upon it until recently and
we're trying to get our life back i'm
glad you are i'm so proud of you you're
you got a lot of balls in the air and
you really do i mean you got a lot of
you cut up your credit cards you're
selling stuff and now i sold your
trailer i mean you got a lot of stuff
going on right
you didn't know when you called all this
is gonna happen yeah but i mean this is
what you do you
you know cause here's the thing it's
like you're going down the interstate
and you realize because gps goes off
that you passed the exit you missed your
turn
so now you are going 75 miles an hour in
the wrong direction yes
the first thing you do is you get off
the interstate
now you're going zero miles an hour in
the wrong direction but zero miles an
hour in the right direction
you go under the ramp under the bridge
get back up on the ramp and go back 75
miles an hour
in the right direction this is a 150
miles per hour change
this is what you're doing so it's going
to give you whiplash
absolutely yeah it's going to shock your
nervous system in a
wonderful way
if this doesn't if this doesn't feel
like a little like what
then there's something wrong with you
that's to be you talked about on another
day but
[Laughter]
i have to wait on dr john to be here
wait till dalone's back wait a little
knees back on we'll talk about your
mental illness but you know it's normal
to shock the nervous system
when you say oh my gosh you know
uh i had a friend of mine who who's a
health nut and he works out all the time
and he decided that he had gotten he
kind of kicked it off and he wasn't
eating right
and he decided he's gonna go all healthy
and so he's detoxing so it's like he's
got the flu yeah
he's like he's drag button around yeah
got his little lip stuck out
like he's got the flu but in you know in
a week
whenever two weeks for this to break out
his diet to change back to healthy
eating
then he'll have more energy he knows
that but his body's going through this
shock yeah of change i've never heard
you give that interstate example that's
a great visual
that's a great because even the speed
you're talking about like when you're
very first getting started it's slow and
then you start picking up speed like
that's a great visual yeah but every
every mile per hour in the right
direction
is on top of the 75 miles an hour that
you were going in the wrong direction
right so it's a big change yeah it's a
real thing and so but it's normal for
the human system
to go oh my god for 10 years you know
i've been eating everything in sight
and all of a sudden i'm going to change
my eating habits and of course your
body's going to react to that
it's going to freak out you know it's
the same thing it's the exact same thing
with your money it's the same thing with
your career
if you decide like i've never i've
always just kind of been a jerk at work
and i'm gonna go to work and smile and
actually work hard
it's gonna shock everybody they're not
gonna know how to act they're going who
are you and what have you done with that
other guy
you know it's the same thing so yeah
just shock it
you know do that do it baby get it up
get let's go
let's go you got this
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost-sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
i'm dave ramsey
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
have you ever asked questions like how
much should i be saving or how much
debt can i pay off how fast can i get
out of debt when's the right way to
invest what's the right way to invest
here's the good news you don't have to
figure out the answers on your own
ramsey plus will guide you every
step of the way all the details of the
baby steps
exactly how to do them when to do them
how to do them
the community is there the coaches are
there to help you with the ramsey plus
membership you get all the digital
teaching you really need including
financial peace university so you can be
confident that you're always doing
the next right thing plus our
world-class budgeting app every dollar
all our tools our guided action steps
help you
make progress on your money goals fast
and that means
no more debt cash in the bank for
emergencies and a real plan
for your future ramsey plus helps you
get small consistent wins
every day that lead to big results and
lifelong habits
to get started today with a free trial
text
trial 233 that's
trial two three three seven eight
nine rick is in saginaw michigan
hey rick welcome to the ramsey show
dave my heart's racing i've waited for
so long to talk to you
we're glad you're here what's going on
yeah we've never lost a patient
you'll be okay no it's racing because
i'm happy i'm excited i want to thank
you uh to start off
just you guys have changed my life and
i's life
so much um we went from massively in
debt to completely debt-free deep into
step six now
uh and because of that she's able to
stay home with our baby so yeah
hey where'd it go yeah yeah it's amazing
i really appreciate it um
now my question arises from something
that i was doing
uh which is part of what you suggest um
and uh i've never heard of this
happening before until it happened to us
and now i i googled the problem and i
found a couple
here and there that happened but it's
rare so i wanted to get your take on it
um she worked for a large regional bank
that had a roth 401k
option which we took full advantage of
as soon as you explained what that was
and uh um
we were really pounding it at that full
15 plus their match which went into a
separate
uh um standard 401k that she had there
um and as of her leaving uh we
called up fidelity and um
went to open a roth a rollover account
right
through fidelity's instructions and that
she was handling it because it's her
account
um and uh we she followed fidelity's
instructions to a t
but i mean the holy ghost is kind of
punching me in the gut the whole time
uh telling me pay attention pay more
attention because i'm kind of the nerd
in the family
uh what i found out happened after they
did it
was that they rolled both of the checks
that they that was sent to them by the
regional banks you worked for into one
rollover ira so now our
roth money is trapped yes when he's
trapped and
yes and what year did that happen it
happened uh two weeks ago
and i realized that as i was funding the
funds
uh according in accordance to your
suggestions you know growth
growth and income uh yeah all that good
stuff and i looked at her
it was 11 p.m at night and i said honey
there's only one account number here
and we've got roth money mixed with
regular
yeah so the good news is the good news
is there's no
there's no tax implication if you undo
it in the same calendar year so
get with a smart investor pro instead of
fidelity online
for god's sakes yeah right yeah sit down
with smartvestor pro they can fix this
for you
now we're in we're in talks with them
and according to
here's my question well according to
them they can choose whether or not they
can just undo it for us
yeah so they're saying that if they
don't choose to do it
that they would try to uh it would bill
us the penalties and taxes and whatnot
of an early withdrawal yeah they they
need to no it's not an early withdrawal
no because you i don't think so
uh but to start to start with i'm gonna
get on
and just have them reverse the thing
they made they made it
that's what we've got in the works yeah
they made a clerical error and that
solves everything
if they don't do it i still think you've
got a case here to make but
that's what i'm wondering if they don't
do it do i need to contact a lawyer or
something or just
no i think i think your tax advisor
because i think this can be undone
but make sure you handle it in this
calendar year
oh absolutely it's scaring the heck out
of me because we got with like thirty
thousand dollars of roth money that they
dumped into this account
yeah and all of a sudden she's a young
woman so
that tax free growth was going to be
huge but now it's 30 years from now
yeah it's all taxable now yeah so yeah
that's not that's not good
so yeah fidelity will fix it fidelity's
not um
they're not uncaring they're just huge
yes and i made sure because it was
recorded phone call i was like just
take this down please my wife is not an
investment professional when you guys
saw two checks come in from one account
you should have had a red flag go up
that said hey wait a minute
some of this is probably ross you know
yeah
well it's just again they're not you're
it matters to you they're so big it
doesn't matter to them and that's why
you use something like a smart investor
pro to do these things instead of a
instead of just an online thing like a
fidelity federally's not a bad company
they're fine
they're just uh this was just you know
inept
is what it amounted to probably yeah
yeah anyway but i i think your
smartvestor pro
it can guide you through this if
fidelity doesn't but i think i think
they're going to be able to reverse it i
it's just a it's a clerical thing the
the the problem will
really be compounded if you let it go
over a calendar year but you're not
going to do that you're obviously game
on so
good stuff good stuff yeah this is um
you know what he said there is a very
interesting he said i had a sense i had
the holy spirit i had a sense that and
man
when that bell rings you need to answer
the bell every time in your life
whatever it is
how many times have we all done
something you know i had a feeling oh
god
every time i haven't listened to it i've
regretted it every
single feeling act on the feeling denise
is with us in atlanta hi denise how are
you
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
good good we have been following you for
10 years so i just want to thank you so
much it's
i love listening to you just great
advice every day
um i've got a question my husband and i
um i'm 57 he is 61 turning
62 this year so we're we're starting to
think about retirement
um we are wanting to we are considering
a move and i just wanted to run numbers
by you
um because the last thing that we want
to do is make a mistake and
add stress into our lives we
have uh roughly 2.65 million
in 401k and ross
thank you thank you we've got um three
about 335 000
sitting in cash a hundred of that is
um an e-fund and not touchable
um about 50 000 in stock options that
are coming do over the next couple of
years
no debt and we're currently saving
about 40 to 50 000 in cash a year
plus contributing to the 401ks and
the ross as well awesome um
we have a home that's paid for
worth about 650 000 is what our real
estate agent is telling us
and we are looking at a home not a
larger home but a home on a little more
land
for um it's around 1.2
um he will probably retire in the next
four years um i will be
a little bit after that um i love what i
do um probably
five to six more years and we just don't
know if we should
wait until we get to retirement kind of
look at the numbers and see how much
cash we've got
to make that move or if it's
um wise to do that now
so you can't quite pay cash for it
because your money's tied up in a
retirement account right
correct yeah well i mean as long as
you're ready to cash out some of the
retirement when you get to 59 and a half
and finish paying it off
obviously you can afford it you're
multi-millionaires um
well done very good if you don't mind
carrying that little bit of debt for a
little while to keep from
cashing out retirement then uh it fits
with our guidelines
if you hate debt then that means you're
gonna have to wait
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that
even in adversity that you have what it
takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out
[Music]
more
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
this is the ramsay show in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt free stage
joshua and logan are with us hey guys
how are you
hey dave we're good welcome where do you
guys live
orlando florida awesome welcome to
nashville
and all the way here to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off
103 056 dollars all right
how long did this take uh 26 months
good and your range of income during
that time we started at 75 and went to
150.
all right cool awesome doubled it
doubled it
so what kind of debt was the 103 000 all
my
student loans all you what's your degree
in i'm a physician assistant and open
heart surgery very good wow
pa huh good good for you so how long you
been out of school
uh three years now okay how long you all
been married
five years on friday oh happy
anniversary
thank you so what happened two years ago
approximately that got you on this uh
that lit this fuse
uh i came home one day from work and i
uh i like to listen to the ben shapiro
show and i
heard you on the show and so i picked up
your podcast listen to it for
a few days and i came home and said uh
hey babe we should try it out
and then i started listening to the
podcast and i just i fell in love with
the plan
i felt like that's really what we needed
we just needed a plan like we knew
we didn't like the debt we wanted to pay
it off we were trying to decide five
years ten years whatever
and then when we heard your plan we're
like this is perfect because we are
we're type a people we're systematic if
we have uh one two three we can do
anything yeah
yeah that's cool yeah good for you
yeah good old ben i was with ben just a
few nights ago he's a great guy
yeah yeah that's fine who knew that i
would end up
on being on his show ended up leading
that it's usually
the way awesome it's very cool very cool
i love it so um
wow very good so tell us what you did
i graduated from nursing school and uh
just we just started working
yeah you know working overtime so that's
how the income doubled
yeah well originally we thought we'd you
know get a dent like four years and then
when coveted hit we were able to pick up
double overtime work
as much as possible and then um he got
his rn license
during this so when he started working
at srn we started making a lot more too
wow oh yeah that ends yeah that's a good
increase very good
wow very exciting how does it feel
amazing
quite an accomplishment yeah yeah
compared to all your friends who are
just languishing in it right
yeah yeah you're like yeah
they don't get it who are your biggest
cheerleaders
uh our family uh our parents on both
sides
helped us through a lot supported us
they believed you could do it yeah
that's cool in addition to the plan what
do you think is the the
biggest principle or takeaway that if
someone was listening right now they're
like okay i've got the plan
what got you through it what was the the
key to getting out of debt
uh i would say it was just um discipline
honestly
yeah it's day in and day out chipping
away at it yeah so you know the stuff
yeah going to work coming home
just day in and day out yeah for me
listening to the show
every day helps me to stay encouraged
and listen to screams i told josh like
after the first couple episodes i was
like we're doing this
yeah and so for me listening to jeffree
screams was really encouraging but
just that daily reminder of why we're
doing it why we're doing it why we're
doing it that's right
so yeah that's so good it's so it's so
hard to stay motivated when you're in a
marathon and you're in a marathon when
you're paying off debt most often
and you know in the beginning you're
excited it's new you've got all this
gusto and then
you know six months in a year and you
start to get okay this is hard we're
still
having to make sacrifices we're still
working overtime but that's so true just
staying motivated
keeping your motivation up it's good
yeah but the good news is out of the
scope of your life 26 months isn't much
that's right yeah and now you're free
for that's right free forever
wow well done you guys i'm so proud of
you thank you
great job so people made fun of you what
did they say
[Laughter]
um mostly our friends you know i met a
lot of uh
men who are like 28 a little bit older
than me kind of more established in
their fields making fun of me paying off
debt instead of investing or
saving for retirement ah okay yeah
they're trying to be intellectual about
their fund-making
yeah yeah yeah my co-workers and they're
broke
yeah my co-worker said things like oh
when you have kids you'll never be
out of debt like you can get different
now but you won't stay that way yeah
like wow will you go back into debt no
no
no they're wrong they're gonna come back
around be like so anyway
that plan can you give me that plan can
you teach me by the way
that thing i made fun of would you tell
me about that help me yeah
that's so true yeah i'm very good you
guys so proud of you excellent
excellent job well done well done
we've got a copy of the legacy journey
for you that is the next
chapter for you guys as you move through
baby step four and on out through six
and leave a legacy and build a legacy
phenomenal
and an extra copy of the total money
makeover for you to pass along
to one of those people who needs to be
working the plan there you go
that'll work pay it forward kind of
stuff so very well done you guys
very very well done all right joshua
and logan orlando florida
103 000 paid off in 26 months making
75 to 150 count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
three two one
[Applause]
this is how it's done yes
that's awesome so well done i love how
last year in the year of copen
they doubled down they took overtime i
mean the nature of what they do it was
you know
easier to do that but man they made the
most of that they actually kicked it
into gear
in a really hard year you know there's a
weird statistic
we just found in this study we just did
surveying
thousands of people ramsey research just
did it uh that
23 when they asked are you better off
this year than last year 23
said no i'm worse off 30 said i'm better
off
than i was a year ago well after covet
yeah
and but what we find is when we get down
into those numbers
it's um you know it has to do with their
attitude
on how they approach it and so i mean
there's people in the medical field who
had the worst year of their lives
because all electric surgery was shut
down they backed away they did nothing
you know they didn't work and uh in some
cases couldn't work
uh and but then other times like these
two they took advantage of it they said
there's lots of overtime available right
lots of people needing our help and so
they dove into it and the most dramatic
was a nurse that heard that debt-free
scream
um a couple of weeks ago apparently she
called in
uh right in the middle of the quarantine
and uh and
she said dave you fussed at me i can't
imagine that happening i find that hard
to believe i can't imagine that
happening
but she had 265 thousand dollars in
student loan debt
single lady and she was talking about
how she couldn't work and i'm like you
can't work there's people's coffee they
need nurses everywhere right now right
she did travel nursing and went from new
york
to chicago to atlanta to new york to
chicago to atlanta
80 hours a week made a half a million
dollars
last year no and paid it all off in one
year
unbelievable that is unbelievable i mean
that's talk what you're talking about
though she stepped into it that's right
rather than
back from it that's right she saw the
problem as an opportunity yeah yeah well
last year after i said you need to get
off your butt but yeah
after you fussed her we had um academy
open enrollment last spring you remember
this and
and there was a ton of women that came
into my coaching group we we worked
through several workshops specifically
on
pivoting adapting seizing the
opportunity and there are women in my
coaching group that made more last year
than they've ever made before in their
businesses because they did the same
thing and it has to do
with attitude not necessarily
opportunity not even the type of
business they were in
but the attitude and the willingness to
go for it double down
and find new ways to do stuff now
because i mean if you were in the
service industry last year you got
screwed
because your government shuts your
company down and put them out of
business
i mean all the maids fell doing hotels
all gone
you know all the servers gone yeah you
know all the cooks and the chefs
gone you know and for a period of time
anyway and depending on
some states are still gone right uh some
cities are still
nuttier than a fruitcake i mean it was
easier to flatten the curve on the
cove than it was flatten the curve on
the stupid it was
unbelievable man it's still going and so
and these people are out of work man
yeah
and they're struggling and and it's a
heart that's the 23 percent that said
it breaks my heart from because these
are people that couldn't afford it and
it was the hardest working people on the
dead gum planet that's right
and so if you're still sitting around
waiting on your restaurant to open you
don't need to
you need to go do something else that's
right you need to step into this and go
kill something
there's something needs to happen here
you need to go bust something in the
nose baby
and that's what these people have done
that have been successful it's very very
interesting
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today isaiah 54 17 when
god is for you no weapon formed
against you will prosper helen keller
said optimism is the faith that leads to
achievement nothing can be done without
hope
and confidence julie is with us in
los angeles hi julie welcome to the
ramsey show
hi dave and christy thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
um so i have a question i am paid on
mondays
on a bi-weekly basis so i normally get
two paychecks a month but this month i
will be receiving three paychecks
rather than the normal two paychecks uh
because there are five mondays in the
month
always have my questions every year
budget
during a three paycheck month what do i
do with the third paycheck
you're doing your budget wrong
you should do a budge a unique budget
every single month
and your budget for them the principal
for doing a budget for a given month is
you figure out what your income is for
that month and you spend
that income on paper that month
so it's not per paycheck juliet's per
month
does that make sense so like you have
your monthly expenses so you're trying
to do a template where you use a
the same template for every single month
and it's not true
every month is different they're not
substantially different but every month
is different
and so quit trying to do a template that
works for every single month
just say this month how much money have
i got coming in
i've got to give every one of those
dollars an assignment
okay so i look at it as the three
paychecks for this month so i have a
larger
income for this month exactly
exactly so if you're running your
household where you're existing on a two
paycheck month
this ends up being the same as a bonus
and then you can put all that extra
to whatever baby step you're on exactly
that's your debt it's your debt if it's
your
emergency fund whatever that looks like
for you you got two
you have two of these magic months a
year when you're paid by weekly
okay it happens twice a year because you
you get um
you get paid i mean 26 times you get
paid
instead of 24 times so it happens two
times a year
okay so it's not a matter of rolling
over that third paycheck
it will apply to the month of may and
then i'll
not as long as you're able to live on
the income that is two paychecks
represents which i suspect you are
yeah yes okay yeah so in
it's it's just the same exact thing as
said if the boss came in and said hey
i'm going to give you a bonus
well you wouldn't go what do i do with
that no you just give every one of those
dollars a name and you use it for the
baby step your own
you're on baby step two you're doing the
dead snowball it's the next debt down
it's going to get all the money
and you're going to throw it at it
you're going to keep rolling and so it's
like you get a bonus check
twice a year that's really what it
amounts to if you if you've set yourself
up to where you can live on the two
checks
which it sounds like you have so good
job but that's a
that's a normal thing that happens to a
lot of people budgeting so it's a good
really good question to bring up
jorge is with us in uh laws are in reno
nevada hi
jorge how are you i'm doing great how
about yourself
better than i deserve how can we help
all right
hi yes i have a question um so i
recently
i just got divorced and um
uh i'm i'm 30 i make about 50 000 a year
and i am currently 24 000 in debt
i just started doing your um your baby
steps and i'm on step number two
my question is i have five thousand
dollars in
um credit card debt four thousand
dollars
in um lawyer's fee uh two thousand
six hundred and eighty dollars in back
child support
and i owe ten thousand on a car payment
so i'm trying to figure out which should
i tackle first the bank child support
the credit card or the lawyer
uh we normally would tell you to list
your debts smallest to largest pay
minimum payments on those are you paying
payments to your lawyer
uh yes okay then list your debt smallest
to largest pay minimum payments on
everything but the little one and attack
the little one the only thing i move
ahead of that
order is irs or child support
because taking care of your children is
a primary goal of dads
and moms i agree and so uh it just so
happens your child support by
marriage is also your smallest debt
so it also it so for two reasons it's
number one
but if it were not your smallest debt i
still would move it to the front because
it is not a
a debt it's an obligation i mean it's a
different kind of thing morally
and so you know and the irs has such
high penalties
and interest i would move it up there
too and they've got unlimited power so
i'm
those are the only two i cheat on the
debt snowball everything else regardless
of interest rate
i just leave them in that order and so
you know you're gonna pay minimum
payments on your credit cards minimum
payment on your car
minimum payment to that lawyer knock
this 2600 out but you ought to do that
in less than two months right
oh yeah i mean a month and a half yeah
so as soon as you're caught up on that
then you're going to start really
chunking on that lawyer and getting rid
of him that's going to be two wonderful
things to not
to have in your rear view mirror agreed
i strongly agree yeah and then you can
start attacking those credit cards how
many different credit cards are there
it's just one uh i took it out to put
for a down payment for the lawyer
oh good lord this is all lawyer except
the car then so it's all about the
divorce except the car
exactly unfortunately yeah i'm sorry
how long were you guys married uh we
were married for
about a year and a half oh my goodness
how many kids do you have
yeah one just one yeah just one wow
what a heartbreak yeah okay well yeah i
mean you got you got nine thousand
dollars with a lawyer here huh
ouch yeah it was supposed to be cheaper
um unfortunately the divorce itself was
perfectly fine but the custody for my
son was
was what caused us the most headache
luckily
i mean the lawyer's like you know what
i'll just give you a discount just pay
me
4 000 and that's it we'll call it even
yeah okay
wow okay you got it done and so yeah
you're going to plow through both of
those
really quick all of this really quick
because now you got one job and you're
not distracted anymore with all this
other drama
and you're going to feel such freedom
financially when you get these debts
especially
all the non-car debts behind you not
just from the financial standpoint
but from the emotional standpoint not
having to pay on that memory
and that pain you know what i mean yeah
you're going to feel such freedom
on the other side of this how old are
you and you can get through it
yep i'm 30 okay
all right yeah so good news is you're
getting a fresh start at 30 huh
yes yes yes i am uh
i'll try not to make the same mistakes
again but i mean
uh yeah yeah i hear you well me too i
understand
wow ouch that's no fun at all
so the um
debt snowball in this case it actually
laid out perfectly
oddly enough but the idea of
the sense of traction you get of
knocking a debt out
is a big deal yeah it just really sets
you free
and um you get this emotional momentum
when you pay off one that leads you
straight to the next one yes and the
momentum is
that's right the momentum propels you
forward and people always argue on the
interest rate
but when you get that smallest debt by
balance paid off
the motivation you get more and more
fired up to attack the second one and
then the third one and so on it's so
much more about motivation
and momentum than math and the interest
rates
and so i just it's amazing to see the
success and the research shows this that
people
stick with the plan when they see the
progress and have the momentum
from doing it this way yeah and what's
weird is it even adds more momentum
when it's a debt associated with
something that you hate yeah
the pain associated pain like the you
know get the
lawyer behind me get this child support
child support behind me
get you know there's a that's an extra
level of momentum emotional momentum and
freedom that's right it sets you free to
move on to the next thing
that's that's a big deal you guys it
really is and that's sometimes when i'm
doing a debt free screen with people i
ask them what's that one debt you paid
off that you just hate those people
because there's something about that
that drives you you know it's like i
want you people out of my life forever
yes i can go back and name them in
detail and it was 35 years ago yes
oh my gosh i hate you people yes i'm
never being dead to american express
again
i hate american express oh hate them
yeah it's that exact situation so
good show christie that's great good job
good job james and kelly in the booth i
am dave ramsey your host will be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember
there is ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
[Music]
jesus
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
you